so with the house of M starting on
Monday I thought it would be interesting
to spend the weekend and basically do a
series of videos or maybe just a video
really is kind of a test to see how you
guys would feel about us going through
the chronological order of events and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
reason why is because I think it would
be fun to compare and contrast what's
going on with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to what's happened in the comic
books that we can get this really cool
idea of how things are unfolding in a
way that really presents the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as its own separate
reality from what's going on in the
earth-616 universe now what we're gonna
be doing in this video is we're gonna be
focusing on everything before the 20th
century that is to say everything before
the year 1900 and so what we're gonna
find is that while a majority of things
that were given dates really took place
during the 20th century prior to the
20th century we're gonna find ourselves
delving into the realm of conjecture and
speculation the reason being because
we're not really given any dates in
terms of when things happen we're just
kind of shown things as they've unfolded
up until really this the Marvel
Cinematic Universe began to unfold with
regards to the earthbound characters so
what we know is that we can consider
this I guess point 0 we can consider
this the very first thing that really
took place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when the cosmic entities
created the Infinity stones now this
information comes to us from the
guardians of the galaxy which is where a
majority of our information will come
regarding the cosmic events that have
taken place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but what we know is that at
some point along the line the the cosmic
entities did create the the infinity
gems are the Infinity stones as they're
referred to in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we just don't know when or why
now unlike what the comic books in the
in the comics the way the Infinity
stones were created or with it the way
they came into existence was because
again if you recall our discussion about
the Infinity Gauntlet we talked about
how as Stannis was explaining it to us
in the very beginning of the earth-616
universe there was simply just a PE
that was some sort of being now we don't
know if this being existed alongside the
other cosmic entities although most
likely it did
that characters like Galactus were born
or I guess existed prior to the
earth-616 universe and then came into
existence with the birth of that
universe but at some point along the
line this I guess this being for lack of
a better word had come across the
information or basically learned that
because of the fact that there was
really no equal to it that it had delve
into the realm of loneliness it
basically succumbed to the fact that it
is absolutely alone and so what it did
was it dispersed its energies among six
infinity gems and then the infinity gems
were scattered among the cosmos now
that's the Marvel earth-616 comic book
version again in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we don't know why this was done
and in fact we may never figure out we
may never find out why this happened it
may be that this is Marvel simply just
saying this is how the Infinity stones
came into existence and that'll be it or
we may learn later on maybe even from
mistress death or somebody like that the
reason why these Infinity stones were
created but what we do know is that
after these gems came into existence
after the Infinity stones came into it
came into existence in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that the Celestials
somehow got a hold of the power Jim now
again this comes from guardians of the
galaxy and with the power Jim these
Celestials began going about the process
of judging other planets now this is
when we begin to get a little bit of a I
guess maybe mishmash here and there
between the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and the comic books and the comic books
the Celestials were of course
responsible for the creation of life on
the planet Earth more so than that they
were responsible for the creation of
mutants and so what we had seen is that
while the Celestials had gone around and
judged and travelled to other planets
the Celestials had never actually
wielded the infinity gems in the
earth-616 continuity and so this is
really interesting for us because we're
basically seeing what what happens when
beings like the Celestials gain absolute
power or a vast amount of power using
the power stone now what we don't know
about the Celestials is whether or not
they're the same kind of Celestials we
saw and the earth-616 universe and the
reason why is because with the
Celestials as represented to us in the
end the guardians of the galaxy they're
using the power gym and the Celestials
have no real need for the power gym
because
is there really isn't anybody that could
really oppose them for the most part in
terms of their physical prowess oh the
power they're capable of in the
earth-616 continuity now there are
characters like Galactus of course
eternity and different beings like that
but in terms of your normal mortal
earthbound characters or even immortal
characters none of them really possess
so much power they could really
challenge the Celestials and so it's
interesting to see the Celestials
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet or
wielding the power gem which begs the
question are the Celestials not cosmic
entities in in the normal cinematic
universe are they simply just the result
of aliens who have progressed to a
certain degree that they have a vast
amount of power and then wielded the
power Jim now from here again as the as
the collector had shown us in guardians
of the galaxy we had seen where the
Celestials had at some point in time I
guess maybe either succumb to the power
of the power gym or at least recognize
that it was really more power than they
could control and so they locked the
power gym away on the planet Morag now
of course the planet more like is the
planet that guardians of the galaxy
itself picks up on when we first meet
Peter quill now again along this
timeline continuing on we eventually
come across a point again we don't know
an exact date here when the Kree show up
on the planet Earth now once again
keeping in mind that we really have to
delve into the realm of conjecture and
speculation here we don't know why the
Kree showed up to the planet Earth
but again wherever sling back to the
comic books the Kree had arrived on the
planet earth because the planet Earth
was really this a strategic location
between the warring empires of the Kree
and the scrolls and it was really one of
these instances where the the first
person to basically grasp this planet is
going to have a strategic benefit over
the other and so when the Kree had
arrived on the planet Earth they began
experimenting with humans and as a
result they created the Inhumans now the
Inhumans of course develop their powers
when they use the Terrigen crystals and
as we had seen the the Kree had
apparently created something called
diviners now this again is a breakaway
from the Marvel Comics and the reason
being is because the diviners didn't
really exist in Marvel Comics the
Terrigen crystals were in fact housed
within the Empire of Attilan
in humans would actually have to go
through a relatively similar process to
what sky went through in order to become
in humans that is to say they would
basically walk into a giant room they
would be engulfed in the Terrigen mists
they would take on this this really
solid maybe rocky form and then emerge
from it like a I guess would be like a
butterfly emerging from a cocoon and so
as a result they would then be endowed
with whatever form was I guess they had
previously they were supposed to take on
given the genes of the Inhumans and of
course if you're curious about learning
more about the Inhumans I have a video
on that that you're welcome to look at
but again we're not really given a
timeframe as to when this happened all
we know is that the Kree most likely
left the planet due to a conflict
between themselves and the Inhumans the
fact of the Terrigen crystals were being
housed in these diviners that were later
discovered during the perhaps on agent
Carter TV show or during a lifetime of
agent Carter before she I guess gained
her own TV show and was expanded on
during the agents of shield TV show
tells us that that basically the Kree
had most likely been using these
diviners or these Terrigen crystals as a
way to maybe keep the Inhumans under
control we don't really know but most
likely the Inhumans had somehow found a
way to rise up against the Kree and as a
result they had most likely managed to
kill either one or two Kree which is the
reason why we had seen a dead Cree and
the episode of Tahiti and then in turn
the Kree left the planet and so what we
do here is we actually leave a lot of
the earthbound stuff behind in terms of
the Kree and the Inhumans and we
actually jump to the realm of a for to
the realm of Asgard and if you recall
for the dark world and one of the things
I guess the the focal point and one of
the things that four had talked about
was something called a convergence and a
convergence as it was explained was when
all nine realms line up and when they do
individuals can actually jump between
each realm they can literally walk
through a dimensional barrier and into
another realm and for those of you guys
who had recently finished our discussion
on the incursions this is basically what
that is this is an instance where by
dimensions somehow basically press in on
one another and you can literally walk
from one to the next as if you were
passing through some kind of invisible
wall now because this incursion is
taking or this convergence had taken
place this is what Malekith and the Dark
Elves have used
their first attempt to take over a scar
to to basically take over the nine
realms entirely and so this entire
backstory was given to us at the
beginning of Thor the dark world this is
when we had seen Odin telling us that
his father was able to lead a army
against Malekith and the dark Dark Elves
and then take the ether back and keep
the ether under control now again the
ether is simply another aspect of the
Infinity stones this is actually the
reality stone and so the question that
we have to ask here is how is it that
the I guess the ether had come into
existence or coming to the the hands of
malakut how it was he was able to get
ahold of it we don't know that we really
haven't been told how it is that that's
happened all we know is that once for
the father of Odin had been successful
in I guess in defeating Malekith and the
Dark Elves that he had hidden the ether
away and some other dimensions someplace
where he figured nobody would be able to
find it but of course as we knew or as
we have seen with them Thor the dark
world
Malekith and a handful of Dark Elves
were able to keep themselves in a
suspended animation of source so they
could escape the judgment and the defeat
of Bor and then eventually rise back up
again now from here do we travel back to
earth and we pick up with the battle of
tones berg i think is how you pronounce
it I'm not really sure how to pronounce
a lot of these phrases from from Norway
but this is the conflict we had seen
that was the basis behind the beginning
of I guess the beginning of Thor this is
when we had seen the frost giants attack
Odin hime I'm sorry from Jotunheim and
them attack I guess Midgard or attack
earth for the very first time this is
when we had seen Odin who had become
aware of his conflict a symbol and army
and then at a key Odin home actually go
after the frost giants and their own
dimension and this is when Odin had come
across the son of lafi the child that he
would later adopt and named Loki but
what we eventually find here is that
there comes a point where by Odin hides
the tesseract in Norway now again we
don't know how it was an Odin had gotten
ahold of the tesseract he simply just
had it now we may learn in other stories
maybe in times two different movies or
some aspect of another movie how it was
he was able to gain the Tessa
but the fact that he had hated away in
Norway would eventually lead into the
beginning of Captain America the First
Avenger when the red school travels to
Norway under the pursuit of finding
different Asgardian artifacts and I
guess items of legend that leads him to
taking the tesseract away and then using
it as a power source and so again this
is gonna bring a conclusion to the
events of the 20th century but I hope
you guys are really beginning to see how
everything is starting to work together
how it's all starting to come together
but again because of the fact that this
is all pre 20th century we don't really
have any dates we can't say with any
absolute certainty that these things did
happen in this chronological order we
can say that with other films because we
can literally see those events unfolding
throughout other films we can see
elements of The Incredible Hulk
affecting Iron Man we can see elements
of Thor the dark world affecting other
movies we can see these things as they
unfold and so we can relate them to one
another but because all this is stuff
that's simply just hearsay more or less
because it's tales that are told to us
by the collector or things like that
again it's really just the realm of
speculation conjecture and just good
old-fashioned haphazard guessing so with
that being said I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace be sure
to follow me on Twitter there you can
keep up with all the updates from comics
explained and talk to me directly